have you ever had an incredible idea you
couldn't wait to get started on but
halfway through you realized to finish
your masterpiece you simply would need
more time
now assuming you had to deliver you were
forced to lower the bar moving forward
and you couldn't wait to not be working
on it so that happened to me with my
last 3d scene the one i did for
the infinite journeys 3d community
challenge now i take pride in tackling
ambitious ideas with attention to detail
so naturally i tend to bite off a little
bit more than i can chew but this time
was the first time that my ambition got
the best of me so this video isn't about
optimized workflows or the perfect
topology
but rather an honest breakdown of my art
and everything i could have done to
avoid what happened since i was a kid
i've always loved intense activities
whether it's going off jumps on my
rollerblades riding roller coasters
doing martial arts driving fast cars or
hitting six g's in a stunt plane
i'm there for it all so i wanted to
bring a sense of speed and intensity to
my infinite journeys 3d art now at first
i didn't know what to create and after a
few days of unsuccessful brainstorming i
decided to just take a break and go rock
climbing sometimes the greatest ideas
pop up in the in between moments when
we're focused on anything other than the
idea itself
and that's when the perfect idea hit me
or so i thought
imagine a pilot moments before takeoff
attempting to break the land speed
record he starts his rocket car flips a
bunch of switches shifts into first gear
and blasts off the g-forces push them
back into a seat as the background
rushes by and you got little trinkets
wires and straps flapping from the
inside of the car
now i didn't know this at the time
but i had just made a massive mistake i
overestimated the time i had available
and underestimated the workload i was
about to take on
this is something that can quite often
get me in trouble now i will say though
that starting your idea was something as
simple as a sketch is a great way to
creatively keep on track through the
project and building a reference board
is another must do for me as it informs
my art while i create once i had a
direction to go in it was time to open
cinema 4d and block out my 3d cockpit
with blockouts i focus on basic
composition and lighting testing my
concept in a simple 3d form it'd be a
waste of time to lay out details at this
point because i'm still experimenting
with the basic shapes only when i'm
happy with my basic composition can i
move on to the details which honestly is
where it starts to get pretty dark
it was important for me to custom model
as much as possible i feel it's a great
way to get a unique look as opposed to
relying on kit-bashed assets that
everyone recognizes now in theory
i'm all for this but in practice i did
not have the time yet i modeled away
everything from the racing chair and the
dashboard to the steering wheel and the
vintage monitor to the roll cage and its
details minimalism was not an option
here i still have to animate i still
have to texture i still have to render
and i need an additional two to three
weeks at this rate i realized mid
project that i had gone too far it was
an extremely tedious and horribly slow
process because
i'm honestly not the best 3d modeler and
the only saving grace
was mcmaster carr they're an industrial
equipment supplier who also provides cad
models too it definitely came in handy
for some of the smaller switches and
knobs when time got really short
now with four days from the deadline i
had to call it quits on the modeling
looking back i realized i put myself in
this situation by choosing an overly
ambitious idea if my original goal was
to capture a sense of speed and
intensity i should have just crafted a
simpler idea focused on that
specifically
because now i only have four days to
texture find a 3d character animate that
character build three custom huds in
after effects fine tune my lighting
somehow render all of this locally
composite in after effects add sound
design and finish the top 100 montage
i was happy to move on to texturing
because honestly it wasn't modeling
and also texturing is a blast for me
adding scratches dirt dust grime smudges
all those beautiful little surface
imperfections really bring a scene to
life and it's super satisfying when you
actually hold on wait a second
i'm not going to see like half of this
detail from
god dang it
you'd think i learned my lesson at this
point
i was procrastinating from doing the
work i was afraid of by doing the work i
enjoyed
but ultimately i was forced to texture
from my main camera view which just
makes way more sense in this scenario a
lesson to learn too late is better than
one never learned
and with three days left it was time to
get smart and cross this finish line so
i busted out rococo's new smart suit pro
2 to drive my character's movement and
the only way to ensure that my movement
connected to the 3d control panel i
built was to reassemble my furniture in
cockpit form get rococo and cinema4d
communicating through livelink and
record some goofy looking tanks yeah
there'd be some cleanup to do but
without the suit honestly i'd have been
screwed now when you have a moccast
character front and center for more than
five seconds in a render you're gonna
see a lot of small inconsistencies
especially in my case when you want the
character to interact with objects in
the scene
luckily sam helped me fine-tune the
tough spots while i continued working
and there was no way i was about to
create my first character from scratch
in one day so i downloaded this guy from
cgtrader.com
one of my favorite sites for 3d assets
two days left all right and it was time
to create a custom heads-up display for
both the dashboards and the crt monitor
i pulled a couple references from nascar
dashboards and some rocket car videos on
youtube i sketched a rough in photoshop
busted out the for real version in after
effects saved that out as a transparent
png sequence and dropped it onto my
dashboard as an emissive material and
with my last half day before rendering i
fine-tuned my lighting using a grayscale
gorilla hdri and i made adjustments to
the sun to best shape my scene for the
atmosphere i faked it by plugging a
simple black and white gradient into an
opacity channel and applied that
material to a series of stretched out
planes to sell the effects the high
speed had on the rocket car i added a
vibrate tag to a few of the levers and
finally i cloned a number of mile
markers across the mid ground to give a
better sense of speed with one day left
i was struck with a genius idea render
farms why don't i just use everyone
else's computer to render this thing
honestly it was my last hope so since
i've always used octane as my renderer
of choice their cloud render farm called
render made perfect sense so i exported
my scene uploaded to the render network
chose the appropriate settings and
watched the frames roll in
it was a dream come true honestly to get
this up and running especially in crunch
time like this the process was fairly
straightforward once i got the hang of
it but it definitely took some stressful
trial and error to set things up so
consider subscribing if you want an
in-depth tutorial on otoy's cloud
service
and finally it just came down to
compositing to simulate the camera shake
i filmed two post-it notes with my sony
a7r ii while watching the render for
timing i 2d tracked the footage using
mocha ae then toned it down with a
simple position expression hooked up to
a slighter control and after effects
some film grain to dirty things up and
after a long 25 days
my render was finally complete
[Music]
some projects flow like water and are an
absolute joy throughout
other projects offer a massive challenge
but proud of the end result because it's
a mark of everything you learned along
the way
then there are projects like this with a
tight deadline and ambitious goals with
an end goal never achieved
to me these are the toughest
you're simply just trying to do your
best and survive until the end he
crossed the finish line felt like
nothing was gained
personally i grossly misjudged the
number of days i had to work on this
and underestimated what it would take to
accomplish the art itself
in the future i need to do a way better
job of being first realistic with the
days i have
and then plan to accomplish something
achievable in half that time then i can
decide whether i want to spice things up
or move on to more important things with
the time i have left
being aware of this tendency before i
start future projects is my biggest
takeaway from this one and even though i
feel like the art suffered in the end i
consider this revelation a big win
[Music]
so what did you guys learn from your
last project
leave a comment down below i'll see you
all on april 30th at 10 45 am pst for
another 3d live stream so subscribe if
you don't want to miss it and until then
keep learning keep growing and thank you
for watching i'll see you guys later
peace
[Music]
you